hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play it is a game
that is supposed to be exceptionally
hard now what that means I've been I
don't know probably means that wait no
wait wait no oh there we go ok probably
means that I'm gonna have a really rough
time with it and you guys are gonna
enjoy the sight of me losing my mind as
I try to get around these puzzles
everything ok now we've hit some kind of
interference Oh something drunk we're
gonna crash the back you eight oh no we
lost it why this shouldn't be happening
oh that didn't look good
those poor little whew that was scary at
least we all escaped right guys right oh
no I'm all alone guys ok oh now I'm sad
ok so basically I saw a few videos about
this you I wonder why this ship
teleported me here alone I hope everyone
else too got out ok so basically you
have one ability and that's just to flip
upside down until you flip upside down
to get through the levels and try to
avoid all these goober gases here that
are trying to stop you get get that cuz
you stop signs okay so it's it's
sometimes kind of tricky to figure out
what you're doing and there's like these
well alright then okay alright just stop
it just stop it i'm trying to be a
little bit seriously i found a shiny
trinket one out of twenty which probably
means that i'm gonna be here a while
that was a relatively easy one so i'm
just under the assumption that they're
gonna be a lot harder
well i mean i'm almost definitely gonna
be a lot harder i really don't know what
to say about it other than just wait
until it gets a lot worse than it is now
if you're like this doesn't seem so bad
trust me I've seen some things where
it's probably not help can anyone hear
this message pilot is that you captain
you're okay something has gone horribly
wrong with the ship's teleporter I think
everyone has been teleported away
randomly they could be anywhere oh no
I'm on the ship it's badly damaged and
but it's still intact where are you
captain I'm on some sort of space
station it seems pretty modern there
seems to be some sort of interference in
this dimension
okay I'm broadcasting the coordinates of
the ship to you now I can't teleport you
back but if you find a teleport anywhere
nearby you should be able to teleport
back to me okay
I just so happen to find a teleporter
lying around you know in a junkyard or
some trash can I'll pick it up and I'll
use it
[Music]
I definitely like the retro feel of the
music well I mean this whole game is
obviously very retro because it's it's
all frickin pixelated but I mean
sometimes you can overlook that for a
games true oh hello don't kill me I'm
gonna live
ah there we go oh oh it's another one of
those shiny things I probably don't
really need it but it might be nice to
take it back to the ship to study okey
dokey
hi buddies what are these things anyway
oh hello these are like little soldiers
er oh I'm gonna I'm not gonna like this
game mi the thing is you can't flip
while you're in midair
you have to flip-flop on the
flippety-flip hey I found a shiny
trinket now if I just kill myself while
I respawn back at the checkpoint without
it or will I actually have it there I
probably won't have it okay JC here okay
got it
oh and immediately kill myself come lose
or am i there we go alright let's enter
to view it and quick safe okay alrighty
then never mind never mind
Wow what are you you big whatever you
are gonna stop blocking my path
[Music]
all righty then all righty then
yep death is what I wanted that's
exactly what I wanted to do wait what do
I do
[Music]
okay well is that all I needed to do oh
that's right because I can't I can't
flip in midair I need to go all the way
down to be able to flip back up what the
hell is that thing that a ghost ego oh
no it's a Giga ghost okay yup oh right
on top of it
why is there ghost oh my
or the hell are those things so I have
you haven't oh whoops
if you haven't determined Oh God dang it
if you haven't determined it in this
dimension is horrible monsters here
ready to kill me at any moment a
teleporter I can get back to the ship
with this you say so man captain level
complete
you've rescued a crew member for remain
there's actually to continue so doctor
have you any idea what caused the crash
there's some sort of bizarre signal here
that's interfering with our equipment
it's caused the ship to lose its quantum
position collapsing us into this
dimension oh no I didn't understand a
word of that she'll be able to fix you
can get out of here as long as you find
the rest of the crew okay really don't
know anything about this place
our friends could be anywhere they could
be lost or in danger
can they teleport back here not unless
they find some way to communicate with
us we can't pick up the signal and they
can't teleport here unless they know
where the ship is so what we do we need
to find them head out into the dimension
and look for any where they might have
ended up okay where do we start well
I've been trying to find them with the
ship scanners but it's not working but I
did find something
oh these points show up on our screens
and having high energy patterns a good
chance there teleport which means
they're probably built near something
important it could be a very good place
to start looking okay okay head out see
what I can find I'll be right here if
you need any help all righty then
bye-bye
what's over here is there anything
special on the ship that I need oh oh
wait where am i oh I just dropped down
at the bottom of the ship alright then
good enough place to start for me I
don't need anything fancy I'll just go
on the merry way music
okay where am I going I seem to be
descending into a pit of hell
Oh oh good thing I got lightning
reflexes I could use a checkpoint though
there's one I've no idea where I'm going
wow I dropped through the ceiling cool
all right so this dimension is how
absolutely wonk applied but hopefully
I'll be able to find my friend I mean oh
I can teleport anywhere in between
places of gone
oh okay all right I got it now I don't
need to take that one right away
the music is shifted Wow Wow what's
happening whoa whoa whoa whoa hey come
on now don't be like that
ah ah dude mutters okay okay I got the
one good is that a monster about to eat
me at the bottom of the screen or gosh
dang it
move your controls yeah there we go oh
right into it you stupid mutt Oh oh
really I can't go up yet is that how
this works
oh crap oh come on don't be like that
hang on oh I get that I can't get that
apparently I can get that come on what
does it do oh no I didn't get that
checkpoint oh no oh no oh no
oh did I lose the trinket thingy oh no
don't tell me I lost it finger thing oh
come on it was perfectly before what the
hell is going on here okay good I got
that I didn't get come on all this takes
is a little precision and not rushing
into things because when I rush into
things that's when I die ah crap oh
goodness oh no am I gonna miss out on
another thingy is there gonna be oh no
it's wrong okay
yeah they need them oh well let's be
honest I wasn't gonna get all of them
anyway and look an arrow pointing me
where I need to go whatever you know
what it probably wasn't all that
important anyway probably and you know
what I probably wasn't gonna beat this
game in the first place
I was probably just gonna row I was
probably just gonna rage quit after a
few episodes or no after a few minutes
there's gonna be a one-off thing oh come
on it's right there don't do that it's
right there oh don't do that I'm
pressing the spacebar
yeah Oh Mother of God stop doing this
[Music]
okay pingas pingas pingas pingas die
yeah where's our checkpoint right next
to this checkpoint is that really
necessary
is that really necessary y'all most copy
but you didn't oh you got me that time
but that other time you almost got me
but then you didn't remember that we're
over that time I outclassed you
I got foxed you I knew what the Fox said
how long is it going for Jesus oh my am
I glad to see ya Oh follows the only one
to escape the ship I thought a million I
knew you'd be okay sorry it's the
situation don't ask why they're all
skubish
or whatever language I'm trying to
interpret which is what they are
I speak well we'd better get back then
there's the teleporter in the next room
waiting you well in your teleport
[Music]
never confirmed you have rescued of the
crew member carrillo remain if you say
so this is getting awfully challenging
actually that wasn't that bad I mean it
was kinda bad but not awful bad oh I see
that whole thing the red section the
entire thing is dis oh my god Oh Oh No
thank you okay so when I need to do is I
need to get to I guess the best place
would be going back to here and then I
could drop out the bottom of that and
see where that goes okay hopefully I'm
right back where I left off I yes I am
indeed and I'm not gonna take the
teleporter because apparently it crashes
my game I can't wait to help you find
the rest of the crew it'll be like old
times there captain you mean old times
when we got sent into the
interdimensional rift and then almost
died when we all got lost in that
interdependent never mind you know what
I've had about enough of your
Vermillion I've got a ship to run and
captaining to do I found a telephone
well that doesn't help me much but okay
I guess that's good it up just in case I
want to get back to wherever the hell I
am
oh boy you're ready to bounce is the
level
I didn't do that oh I get it get ready
to bounce oh I see okay I got oh well
apparently I do not hang on I got this
oh nice nice moves nice moves markiplier
thanks so much I know I'm great I know I
am oh yeah activate terminal it turns
out the key to stabilizing this
dimension was to create a balancing
force outside of it though it looks like
that is just a temporary solution at
best I've been working on something more
permanent but it seems like what
whatever you know what whatever whatever
I don't care I'm just gonna jam out to
the awesome one
[Music]
ah
how do I get to that thing
that was action that actually worked out
quite well I'm actually kind of
surprised but that boy yeah whoops no
that's fun OOP that's also wrong good
thing they put checkpoints here else I'd
be dead a million times over
[Music]
thank you pretty cool I like this a lot
oh yes whoosh yeah you know it seems
like the challenge modes aren't all that
different than the oh I didn't get that
criminal Wow looks like I have another
chance
syntax error well alright then nevermind
sorry do I got damn it okay so there's
gonna be one of those things oh oh
really I got this on the first try and
now suddenly I can't get it what is
going on there we go now do this get the
checkpoint
boingy boingy boingy boingy bonaparte
all right here's your barn I died well
that worked out quite easily okay the
other part isn't so easy this is easy
the other part not so much oh come on
it's kind of confusing with the level
transitions I'm surprised any I'll be
surprised if any of you are able to keep
up with what is going on here
good golly well no I don't mean to
undermine your intelligence I know that
you're all very capable of interspatial
relationships but I mean glumly complex
complex stuff here come on and I mean I
can barely even read the level goddamnit
come on I can barely even read the level
names just because it's going oh come on
it's like I it's in my phone it's two
controls I I don't want to nevermind you
know what you know what never mind it's
like super hexagon it's like it goes a
little farther than I want it to each
time and not cool why can't I get it
never mind you know what never mind they
used to throw checkpoints at me a
million times but now I guess I just I'm
on my own with this one oh yeah baby oh
yeah baby yeah that's what I'm talking
about
now Kent is there another guy over here
Oh could have gotten trapped in there
what would happen if I have been trapped
but I have died
oh no Etta could have just flipped out
never mind access to the control center
is still possible through the main
atmospheric truth is in the yellow
section I'm in the blue section
apparently
[Music]
well at least this one doesn't doesn't
subject me to total death and total and
immediate death so it actually seems
quite easy to get um I don't know
what'll happen if I get all the trinkets
but hey I'm gonna get a lot of them I
guess alright then whoa Wow
really really really you go through all
that just to walk into some spice what a
dick
Oh woah woah woah woah woah woah woah
hey wait a minute what are you doing
here you're helping how how are you
helping you're not helping me how long
is this game it doesn't seem like it'd
be that long
I mean as far as like super hard goes
this isn't like the hardest game I've
ever played it just requires some sort
of precision to it it's not that awful
I know it's called vvvvvv cuz of the
spikes right there oh oh gosh it's sad
to say something there
how's easy that was easy
Oh God oh okay that was easy I always
panic right before I actually do
something yeah there we go oh come on
don't be like that to me well alright
then okay once again can do it on the
first try can't do it on the second or
third or fourth or fifth
oh you're such an a-hole oh come on
[Music]
infuriating cuz it's not my fault not my
fault
this is stupid game's fault yeah that's
it yeah it's who I'm trans day ow else
oh maybe I can damn it
damnit this is gonna be complicated
[Music]
dammit
all I can stand on those things oh
that's that that changes everything
actually probably not it I can get
through this oh god I can get through
this I know I can you guys aren't all
that impressed at calling oh we did that
before oh I get what I need to do in
order to be able to get down there I
need to bounce here and loose okay I
thought you might have thrown a wrench
in me in me on me that's okay I'm here
to rescue you let me explain everything
and then bla bla bla bla what I didn't
understand any of that warrant she's
just a dense mother okay oh well don't
worry follow me everything will be all
right
really he's blue if he was Green II
would die I believe I would be but I I
never I never knew the words all I knew
it was a lie I believe as a lie then
something it was I ignored you oh ah
you've got to be joking me where are we
you look for a way back okay don't look
for my way coz your captain just killed
himself on spikes cuz I'm some kind of
idiot promise you won't leave without me
I promise
don't worry when you're not standing on
the floor Victoria will stop and wave
for you
I like it okay so okay gonna do this oh
well never mind don't Oh God come on
Victoria go there we go no don't get
yourself killed this is what we're gonna
do okay you like that you like that you
did good you could thought it did go
there Victoria is Whoopi yeah there we
go
okay good good are you okay down there
why is everyone else a doctor I want to
go home where are we how did we even get
here well violet did say that the
inference and the dementia Christ got to
have a good I guess something went wrong
find another teleporter think you can
get back to the ship Samia come on you
big whiny baby okay now just hold on
here horses
whoa that's really not what you were
supposed to do there I mean come on ah
come on you daft mother umber go stop
okay oh god this is gonna be complicated
isn't it
oh why are you trying to test my
patience all right good oh boy oh that
sucks for you how do i oh I know what I
need to do don't go back oh God
dingus you such a Dingle head come on
move it
okay we're gonna beat this together jump
oh there we go
ah do as I say we're never gonna get out
of here are we
shut up blue I don't know where we are
now we're gonna get out
oh don't get a sad feel good oh I'm so
depressed I just threw myself into the
spikes and I'm gonna keep doing it over
and over and over it oh so that kills me
huh I got it all right balls and hammer
well alright then why not you know what
add another death pivot Ali I just had
to say oh I don't flip don't flip very
Oh huh game not that hard
it really isn't like that hard okay
Vivian you are going to try my patience
but here we go
[Music]
I'm going to lose my mind it's not that
stop flipping that time I didn't flip at
all that time I drove over to the vice
[Music]
it's not hard it's not hard it's very
odd there we go okay Vivian don't do
nothing I think she'll be fine on the
top ends go hey go yeah you're good now
[Music]
do it okay I got this I got this
oh I don't got it what do you know I
don't got it you want
like a bus passing fluffer I can't get
it oh go stop red light green light red
light okay now I just need to not die
how do I do this I do this I need to get
back that's why I need you don't flip
[Music]
[Laughter]
come on come on we can do it we can do
it we can do all you died I just want to
get through this one part so I can stop
I want to stop playing like Farge I want
to stop playing I really do but I need
to get to a point where I can actually
stop playing oh god why would you throw
yourself into the pit I'm not I'm not
I'm not happy I'm not happy I'm unhappy
I am extra unhappy right now I do not
want okay stop playing now I wanna stop
just get me to the point where I can
stop
why would then she gets so close that
she could fall off
ah
[Music]
what the hell is that all about why
would she do that why would she just
sprint off into her own death she did
that there was no gap there she just
left into the pit why would she do that
she can't be that depressed ah okay
maybe it's oh maybe I got to go off on
the way up cuz that way she'll follow me
and hopefully it'll like whatever you
know what whatever whatever you know
what I don't want to hear all you people
just God I don't want to hear your
stupid judgments about how no you need
to do with this
shut up my first time playing I'll do
what I want to I'll figure it out I'll
figure it out my own pace I know what I
need to do y'all just shut your faces
and let me play cuz I don't even want to
be played right now ah there we go oh
come on there's more there's more
really
oh I know what I need to do let let me
go home
let me ah finally god damn it
teleporter finally no don't crash game
or something while we're trying to
teleport just do it nicely so I can go
home okay you're done I'll recording
this episode way longer than I want to
do I'm done okay I'm done I'm done
alright okay all in all this is a cool
game not that hard it's not that hard
alright oh this is like whoa like bottom
of the barrel hearted difficulty of
games I played ain't that bad so thank
you all so much for watching click in
thanks for more videos that I've done
and as always in the next video
it was clean
over there I don't see any blood I'm
sure come over there he's clean
what's all this
doesn't look clean buddy